in my campaign i said that i wanted to
turn america into one giant switzerland
armed and neutral
absolutely i want a strong military
absolutely
uh
have our borders safe you know
absolutely uh border safe that's not
your position not not boring you think
borders should be open you think people
should come in and out borders
borders should be protected from enemies
and so yes i want you know like i said
one giant switzerland uh except lately
they weighed in on the uk crane thing
but that's another thing so uh no
i want a strong defense
so that i can protect america um but you
were going out you were leading
somewhere else
yeah so
where i was going with this um but since
you went there let's just kind of go to
the border side what are your thoughts
about immigration should people just
cross the border and come to america
they if they choose to
how should we treat illegal immigrants
crossing the border in the south
my position is
three of my grandparents are immigrants
they came over in the early 1900s
and that's what i'd like to see us go
back to which is pretty much open
borders uh
of course
we don't give them free phones
we don't give them free health care we
don't do all of that
and of course if we know
you know
ms-13 gang members or uh you know
terrorists of course we don't let them
in
uh but
what made our country great is people
like my grandparents coming over here
and working hard for the american dream
and that's one of the reasons why i love
my country so much my grandmother when i
was younger used to tell me about the
old country about how you know the old
country they just take all your money so
everybody has the same and you can work
and work and work and you don't get
anywhere
and listening to her stories is really
what made me love this country so much
and she came over here worked very hard
and my grandfather worked very hard from
the same country although they met here
and by the way what's scary is the
country that she came from is denmark
and denmark
you know we don't think of it as
an oppressive country but she would tell
us how yeah they just take all your
money and here you can work hard and
earn a living and by the way when they
died it's not like they had amassed a
huge fortune in fact they uh lived in
florida and lived in well i used to call
it a trailer she would correct me and
say a mobile home
and
but but the thing is is she said in
america you can live how you want and
you can work hard and make something of
yourself open borders
open borders again i'm not going to let
terrorists come across how are you going
to figure out who's a terrorist and
who's not do i look like a terrorist
what if i come don't we no don't we know
don't we don't we keep trying are they
is there going to be an ice would there
be a border patrol workers to come
through would they have to id them so
what do you mean by open border would
there not be a wall would there not be a
fence would there not be anything for
people to come across like i said like
the early 1900s when we when we had more
people come in
i mean now it's the opposite
yeah but but okay so let me get this
part right i want to really understand
this so
if i go if i'm saying i'm coming from
tijuana
what am i crossing if i'm coming from
tijuana
is there a gate is there border patrol
is there an ice in your world in your
administration
this gets into
something that's controversy on the
libertarian party because there are many
who say yes we want to gate and others
who say no
so
i would prefer to have it
so that we have
minimal checking
he here's one of the biggest problems
that we have right now is that
you know because so many people say well
uh people just need to come over legally
but
the system is set up so that hardly
anybody can come over legally so i would
like to flip it around so we've got more
people than not being able to pass
through
but
you know we've got national security
people who know who
some terrorists are they know who the
gangs are so god joe you sound naive
again you can't say that so so let me go
back to it i don't mean to offend you
please i don't mean to be disrespectful
but oh no i like i like experience
so so but go back to the borders so you
didn't answer the question i i want as
clear of an answer on this one as
possible because would we have an ice
and border patrol under a
jorgen jorgensen administration or would
anybody be able to drive by and come to
us
can i answer that if i'm a candidate
again will you have me back if i'm a
candidate no i want to hear it now
because because i'm not a candidate no
but but if but if you were if you're on
this stage by the way i'm not even a
moderator i'm not even asking questions
on the debate if you can't answer the
question to a guy like me
i want to hear it from you because i
think the audience would want to know we
have a lot of your followers and we have
people
who are
considering
a lot of people who call themselves
libertarian that now are like
dude i'm not down with that that just
completely threw me off well yeah and
see that's what i'm getting the
up until recently the libertarian party
platform
was that we only let people across the
border
who are not going to take away your life
liberty or property
and now it's become more open borders so
that's why i'm saying
there's some serious discussion in the
libertarian party and my
my um
promise to the libertarian party was
that i would uphold the platform
and i do like the idea of only letting
people across with um
who believe in life liberty and property
that they're not going to take those
from so so would you have a border
patrol would you have do we verify that
now if i come through today if i go to
tijuana which i've gone to many times
when i was 18 years old
if i'm coming back there'd be a line of
cars and there's a fence that i have to
cross time you've gone through this
before when you go to tijuana absolutely
there's a fence and what do they do
can we see idea of everybody in the car
how about how about making it wider so
the line's not so long first of all i i
think this is a very serious issue joe i
want to go back to what you're saying
though
what is in under your administration
what does that border look like if
somebody is coming
from central or south america because
their country has a lot of problems
they're escaping whatever regime they're
going through they're escaping the
mexican cartel they're trying to come to
america or the isis is trying to figure
out a way to come through the border
because americans are being politicians
are being naive and they open up the
border to say oh we're just an open
border type of place and isis will say
what a naive bunch of people let me get
in there this is an easy way for me to
get in under your administration that
would be open i would suggest that
we have better
um
national intelligence that we don't know
you know that that we don't know who the
dangerous people
we're not going to get everybody but
we're not going to get everybody who are
homegrown terrorists either i mean we've
got a timothy mcveigh who was born on
the soil so
it's never going to be
you never have utopia but what i'm
asking you is would your borders be open
would it look like going from florida to
georgia no
what would it look like
it would look like
everybody who comes across
if national security has said that this
person shouldn't come across it's going
to be more like 99 coming across so what
we have now we just had 2 million border
crossings last year but the problem that
we have now we've got two problems now
we've got
we
we've got an impossible system to become
a legal immigrant
there's there's
low quotas people have to go through uh
too much paperwork
secondly
when they come here we've got a welfare
state
that uh
you know that we say okay we can pick up
on them although
well two things
first of all
yeah i don't like this whole phone idea
i don't know why we're giving people
free phones yeah they're giving they're
giving them phones instead of ankle
bracelets guys i want to simplify this
it's very simple i want to talk borders
let's stay on borders what happens if a
libertarian candidate is the president
what does the borders look like oh that
but that's what i'm telling you i'm
going to let 99 of the people go but to
come
it would be like when my grandparents
came across which is what helped make
our country great uh but i would like to
go back to the charity because i said i
don't you know i don't like the fact
that we've got so many um
uh
welfare programs that they can come back
that they can come in and take advantage
of
however many of them are set up so that
somebody has to be here one year two
years five years depending on what it is
depending on if it's state or local
depending on if it's from one state to
another
uh i don't believe that many of these
people are coming across the border
just for our welfare i think many of
them are coming across for the very
reason that my grandparents came across
which is to work hard and make a better
life for themselves
i i think i still don't have an answer
though that's what i'd like to go ahead
tom joe respectfully
you know in your answers here you're
pointing back to some very real issues
okay
so we have quotas we have h1b quotas for
professional knowledge workers we also
have
certain uh quotas for total immigration
yeah those are things are going on now
but if you were president you know damn
well that an executive order you could
sign on day one you can move those
numbers the question
really is and i would and i would and
what people want to hear is what does
open border mean specifically
for you the libertarian president
and if you could answer that again i'm
letting in ninety-nine percent of the
people she just did and and through
intelligence i'm going to have somebody
stopping somebody that we know
um is a murderer
somebody who uh
you know that we know is a terrorist
from the middle east
somebody that's a gang how are you gonna
know like can you read my okay what
number am i thinking right now
again but what i'm trying to say is how
do you know anybody's motives
how do you know like like are we going
to have a
born identity not board i did any
minority rapport technology to know
who's about to create a future crime and
arrest people on future crimes
you don't know you don't you don't
even today we don't have that kind of
intelligence to track all of that but i
can say the same thing
how do we know that timothy mcveigh was
going to go and bomb people um there are
dangerous people in this country as well
uh you can't know every motive but you
can know who gang members are in mexico
right ms-13
you know them so so then that that that
then goes to
if we already have so many problems like
a timothy mcveigh in our country why
don't we close the borders and make the
requirements clear
but a little bit more picky on who we
hire a company who just hires anybody
and everybody into the company without a
filtering system whoever that hiring
person is in that company should be
fired because there's got to be certain
criterias on how you hire people right
such as
you want me to give you some of them
yeah it's very easy i want to know what
your experience is i want to know what
kind of qualifications you got i want to
know so yeah i want to know what you
bring to the table i want to know how
you're going to make my company better i
want to know how many jobs you've had in
the last five years and how many times
you've changed i want to know what your
attendance is i want to call your three
references i want to put a small
challenge to you in the interview
process and tell you joe i like your
attitude i like the way this is going do
you like to read books i do i want you
to read this book
write a paper on it into this third
interview i want to see what you get out
of this book you're willing to do that
sure if you don't come back 50 of the
time you don't finish a small assignment
like that you're not going to finish a
small assignment when you're hired with
me i just filtered out the people that
don't want to do the work i would filter
those people out instead saying come on
in everybody let's hire everybody so why
don't we just hire 200 people forget
about hiring anybody let people apply to
work for this company and don't even
interview them just bring them all in
that just the logic behind even i'm
thinking purely logically as an operator
i can't logically i should have never
like if i think about myself at a
certain age you should have never hired
me because i was not qualified to be
hired so we should let anybody through
the border okay so let me go we can we
can agree to disagree and get to a more
interesting topic yeah well this is a
very interesting topic and by the way a
lot of people are worried about this
specific topic yeah except i don't think
we're going to get anywhere no but but
but i think but what i do think a lot of
people are here saying you know
you know
there is an answer to that i want to
know what the position is for the
libertarian party on how they manage
that but you you didn't just get like 10
000 votes you didn't get 20 000 votes
you got 1.8 so the way you got one
pointed i'm trying to think did you guys
get 1.8 because there's 1.8 million
libertarians in america is it just
talking to the base of people that agree
with you or you don't talk to people
that maybe challenge the position and
break it down where the others can make
up their mind and say well this makes
sense or this doesn't make sense because
that also gets your argument to be
stronger to say well listen i just sat
down with this guy he asked that
question i don't have an answer for it
guys we got to be ready because
someone's going to ask me this question
under the election we got to get watch
this clip here's how i answered it you
should have said this this is the
position got it let's role play so
that's how i would train my candidate if
i'm their campaign manager if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you